جنه يا
حبيبتي اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم عدد الشهداء والمفقودين
في غزه يتجاوز
29700 بينهم 100 الا طفل بحسب المكتب
الاعلامي الحكومي ووزاره الصحه تقول ان
الاحتلال ارتكب 12 ع مجزره خلال 24 ساعه
تجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه في رابط
للتعليق الا وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تقول ان
دفاعاتها الجويه اسقطت صواريخ وطائرات
مسيره فوق شبه جزيره القرم والبحر الاسود
في حين نشرت اوكرانيا صورا لما قالت انه
صاروخ فرض صوتي روسي من تراس كيجال مؤكده
اسقاط عشره نماذج منه بواسطه نظام الدفاع
الجوي الامريكي بيترس المحكمه العليا
الامريكيه توافق على الاستماع الى
لاستئناف دونالد ترامب ضد القرار الصادر
عن اعلى هيئه قضائيه في كولورادو بمنعه من
خوض الانتخابات التمهيديه للانتخابات
الرئاسيه في الولايه وقد اشارت المحكمه
الى انها ستستمع الى المرافعات الشفهيه في
القضيه الشهر المقبل شركه سبيس اكس تلجا
الى القضاء في محاوله منها لمنع الاستماع
الى موظفين سابقين في الشركه قالوا انهم
فصلوا عن عملهم انهم طلبوا من زملائهم
التوقيع على رساله تنتقد تصرفات ايلون
ماسك وذلك بسبب ما اعتبروه تعليقات مهينه
وغير لائقه يكتبها عبر منصه اكس في
ملا